there's a few instrumentalists
there we go good old McDonald's
cheeseburger still warm
tempted to eat it
okay so we're gonna leave our burger to
digest for a while and the acid come
back later and see what's happened
unlike most of the chemicals I talked
about I can be absolutely sure that
every person watching has a sample of
hydrochloric acid with them as they
watch because hydrochloric acid is found
in everybody's stomach and it's part of
our digestive process so as you're
watching me churning away in your
stomach is hydrochloric acid which is
one of the first stages in which food is
broken down into useable components to
give you energy or make you fat it's say
three and a half hours so we're gonna
see what happens to taste the McDonald's
cheeseburger after three and a half
hours of concentrated hydrochloric acid
okay I think it's absolutely this goes
baby
Oh Sammy the fats aren't really gonna
dissolve very well because in your
stomach there's lots of bile acids and
being in your actual body to do
digestion
this is just pure HDL